this small village near chernihev has
been absolutely destroyed you can just
take a look around and get a sense of
the scope of the destruction about 80
percent of the homes here were shelled
those that are still standing obviously
not livable we've had the opportunity to
speak to a number of people in the
community they've actually come back
because there are small plots of land
that they're planting potatoes and
carrots
food items that will sustain them going
forward and into the winter months
a number of the people who ended up
staying here and hiding in their
basements which are not basements that
we would know but more like
small root cellars outside spent about
21 days hiding hoping to survive
one woman said that you know she's lived
here all her life she was originally
from chernobyl but her house burnt down
in chernobyl during the nuclear disaster
and now she's here and her house here
was destroyed the level of pain of
trauma is just unbelievable so many
people crying when they're talking about
the lives that they once had here that
there was a very close community they
are waiting for help they're waiting for
supplies they are waiting for temporary
shelters and this is one of those areas
that is in desperate need
crystal commansing nova selifka ukraine